[Musique]
je connais londres il ya plein de gens
prêts à payer pour avoir du lourd et
rocco oui et plein d'autres trucs
tu as compris jamaïque
j'ai ce contact
d'abadan soient les sciences démerde
bien on sera au top
qu'est ce que t'en dit
et celui liant venu à sunrise
et devine avec qui douchaient il
ils vont graves sur du matos de ouf on
est de retour
les choses ont changé dans quoi alors
c'est moi qui dirige ce [ __ ] gorgue
non fais gaffe personne vient chercher
dans merde à semmar a dû émis ce soit
alors laisse moi te donner un petit
conseil
les conseils je les donne moi tu veux
dit les tu vends ma d'eau ou alors tu
diras que dalle
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce gars on sait qu'il a deux
frères gémit il fait quoi
j'aime et qui formé
tu sais que je suis hyper fier de toi et
moi et pas fier de moi
[Musique]
depuis qu'on est gamins mec tous les
deux à courir partout dans les rues
on a essayé d'atteindre le sommet et
pour faire ça il faut qu'on se
débarrasse de jamie voulait fumer
[Musique]
l'instance pire je te fais confiance
pour agir justement
quoi qu'on dise pour arriver au top pour
ce que tu veux tu dois pas si trop
trouve que c'est ce qu'ils vont devenir
le sommeil
ça vaut le coup de perdre ce qu'on aime
sa famille
quel autre tueur pourrait avoir dix mois
[Musique]